down in the great state of Georgia the
first days of the runoff campaign are in
full swing with Rafael Warner clearly in
great fear of Herschel Walker and he
starts right up ramping up smear tactics
against Herschel claiming that he has a
disturbing history
um Mr Warnock so do you take a look
this is a choice about competence and
about character
and when it comes to character we all
know that it doesn't get any better for
my opponent
sadly I'm running against someone who
lies about every aspect of his life
his own staff says
he lies
like he's breathing
I'm just repeating what they said
his own staff
and we've seen that Herschel Walker has
a disturbing history
a pattern of violence against women
against his own family
and he takes and he refuses to take
responsibility for that
uh let's see uh in 2020 your wife Mr
Warnock claims that you tried after a
domestic dispute dispute to use a weapon
known as an automobile to run her over
and in fact ran over her foot uh you
were arrested for obstruction of justice
uh in a case involving child abuse at a
camp you were running in which five
instances were discovered to varying
degrees on top of the character issue
you're the guy that's friends with the
Rabid racist and anti-semite Louis
Farrakhan uh you're the one that praises
the uh ever so controversial Reverend
Jeremiah Wright who said GD America the
Sunday after 9 11. you're the one that
prays the murdering dictator uh Thug
Fidel Castro I want to talk about
character let's make it a race about
character because Herschel Walker is
seeing more and more momentum ahead of
this December 6 runoff clearly that man
Raphael Warnock is afraid now he is
hauling in well over 3 million as
Herschel did on the first day of the
runoff for the campaign here with more
on this and of course the situation out
in Nevada is Lindsey Graham South
Carolina Senator let's start in Nevada
uh you've been following these numbers
closely uh we had anticipated we thought
there was about 87 000 ballots in Clark
County that's heavily Democratic so it
turns out there's only 50. now after
tonight's drop there's only about 38 000
votes left in Clark County and then you
got a lot of votes and counties that
favor Adam laxalt as a what 13 14 000
vote lead what does that tell you
uh Adam's going to win so there's a
pathway in Arizona uh uh Carey Lake told
you about how we can get there in
Arizona there's a 20-lane highway in
Nevada you can land the space station on
the pathway that Adam laxov has 60 of
what's left are same-day ballot
drop-offs there are people she can't get
there from here 4 000 votes are going to
come in pretty soon we think from rural
uh Nevada to make up for what you saw
today she can't get there
Lindsay's going to win this race one
County just came in uh uh and apparently
Adam laxalt which county was it it was a
smaller rural County and that is plus 1
000 for Adam laxalt boy you're like
Nostradamus
you know what I tell you I don't get
paid nearly enough a matter of fact I
don't get paid anything it's probably
legit they don't get paid he's going to
win Okay so so he's going to tell you
tomorrow how he wins they're counting
votes in Arizona I like where we're at
in Arizona I love where we're at in
Nevada what are we going to do in
Georgia we're going to vote again okay
now what uh Warnock said is the sign of
a loser that press conference today when
he went after Herschel she tells me he's
losing and here's one rule you should
never get forget in politics
the nightmare for an incumbent is to be
in a runoff Warnock has been in office
for years he raised a hundred million
dollars every media Outlet in the
country tried to destroy Herschel and
lacks uh and a warn act fell short if
you don't win the first time as an
incumbent you're not going to win the
second time in a runoff Purdue and
Leffler lost warnock's gonna lose you
can't buy a seat but the lack of money
can make can lose a seat and I worry
that Blake didn't have enough money
against Kelly now Herschel got out spent
two to one we're going to do this thing
again December the 6th join team
herschel.com tonight right now blow up
the internet let's have the best day
we've ever had I'm all in I'm moving to
Georgia I'm going to do everything I can
to help Herschel I'm going to knock on
doors I'm going to call call people that
I know in Georgia team herschel.com
Warnock is going to lose if we give
Herschel the resources to get his
message out and here's the most
important point I'm going to make
tonight they're they're trying to story
Herschel to deter young men and women of
color from being Republicans if they
destroy Herschel it will deter people of
color from wanting to be a Conservative
Republican because you just have your
life ruined we cannot let that happen we
need his we need to have his back if
Herschel wins he's going to inspire
people All Over Georgia of color to
become Republicans and I say all over
the United States Herschel Walker is a
nightmare for liberals he's an
African-American conservative they have
belittled him they have treated him like
crap his family stand by Herschel
tonight if you can give give if you know
somebody that can give ask them to do it
teamhercial.com the conservative
movement for people of color is on the
ballot in Georgia we must help people
like kershel for the benefit of our
country in the future of conservatism
team herschel.com please
wow very powerful
Senator Lindsey Graham thank you thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else